- First of all, welcome to re:Invent 2025.
I hope day one is going well for you.
My name is Enrique Bastante.
I am a customer solutions manager
with AWS Strategic Accounts
and I'm really excited
about this session today
for a couple of reasons.
First of all, as part of my role,
I get to work closely with Capital One
on some really cool stuff,
including some of the things
that you'll hear about today.
But also because resilience
is actually one of my favorite topics
when it comes to Cloud.
It cuts across every industry,
it's important to everyone,
and you may or may not know this,
but Capital One
is actually really,
really good at resilience.
They're often regarded across AWS
as a world class organization
when it comes to resilience practices.
So I'm really excited for you
guys to hear about it today.
I've got with me two leaders
from their enterprise
platform organization
and they're gonna talk to you about
how Capital One goes about
building high resilient
platforms for business
critical applications
that run a massive scale.
They're gonna talk a little bit about
how they got to where they today,
some of the challenges
they faced early on,
some of the decisions that
they made along the way,
and some of the best
practices and lessons learned.
But they're not gonna stop there.
They're gonna talk to you also
about where they're headed.
So some of the more
advanced resilience patterns
that are implementing now
to continue to build more resilience
into these business critical applications
because as you know,
when it comes to the stuff
that runs your business,
you always have to
continue to raise the bar.
So welcome again, thank
you for joining us.
And with that said,
I'm gonna pass it over to Sobhan.
- Thanks. Thanks for
setting the stage for us.
First of all,
good afternoon everyone.
Thanks for joining us today.
I'll start with a simple question.
How many of you are using
any of Capital One apps
like our shopping,
banking, or any of our services?
A lot of you.
So our, all of the services apps
are built on top of our modern platforms.
So today, we are going
to focus on our journey
as a platform company
and what are the principles
that we believe in building the platforms
and our focus on reliability,
the architectural patterns,
and the best practices that we adopted
to gain our customer trust.
Platforms.
The platforms are nothing but a digital
Lego blocks
that are leveraged to build
our customer capabilities,
our customer functionalities.
So which we can use
to build similarly like a
vibrant city with a Lego blocks.
So before 2019,
we used to have a duplicated capabilities
across our lines of business.
For example,
our line of business like card,
bank used to build the
payment capabilities
or like transaction
processing capabilities
as per to support their business needs.
So we observed
a non-standardized architectural patterns,
a duplication of data.
For example, if I'm a customer
that have both a banking account
and as well as a credit card account,
my customer data is duplicated
across these lines of businesses
in a different format
and we spent a lot of developer effort
and the runtime engine cost.
With that
we incurred
and we have an impact
on our speed to market,
our business capabilities,
and also scaling our platforms.
And in turn, it resulted
to our customer trust.
So in 2019, we declared ourself
as a platform organization.
So we put a heavy investment
on building the foundational
structures or platforms
that are not just a reusable capabilities,
but also that are scalable,
reliable,
that are trustworthy.
So some of the platforms that we built
throughout this journey,
there are multiple
flavors of these platforms
that can be leveraged by
both our internal customers
like our developers,
our LOB partners,
and as well as our business
state business holders,
and also our external
customers and the end users.
Some of them are like
the developer platforms,
like the CICD platform
where we streamlined
our deployment processes
with a lot of controls,
guardrails embedded into it
so that every engineering team
or an engineer can benefit out of it
and they don't need to reinvent the wheel.
Similarly, we
resolve the arbitrary uniqueness
across lines of business
by building the core
business platforms like
our transaction processing platform,
our payment processing platform,
to provide the support across
a seamless experience across
all lines of businesses.
And we have invested building like
customer interacting platforms
like identity platform,
or a messaging platform
that provides a seamless
customer experience.
Irrespective of what type of
platforms that we build on,
our objective is how we can scale as a
organization.
We can scale,
these platforms can scale
based upon the trust that
we get from our users.
So to get that secure,
that foundational trust,
we believe our platforms,
our modern platform has to stand on
seven foundational pillars.
We are going to...
All of these seven pillars are critical,
but today we will be
focusing on our first pillar
reliability.
I'll take an example of
like if I'm a customer
and trying to make a payment
and my deadline is today,
I use a Capital One app,
my payment was not successful
on the first attempt.
I retried it,
it's still not gone through.
As a customer,
I'll look at my other
options to make that payment.
So with that,
I'll as a company,
I'm losing my customer trust
and also the business.
So in this like journey,
the availability of your platform
and the resiliency are very important.
So your availability
is going to be measured
based upon your uptime.
So uptime is a classic metrics
that can help
to define your service
is operational or not,
and your success rate.
Even though the ops
service is up and running,
if the customer transactions are
ending up within errors,
that means they're not happy.
So how can we measure the success rate?
So we aggregate all the
requests that we receive
as a platform
and out of it how many
are actually errored out.
So as an industry standard,
we measure using those with nines.
Resilience play a critical role.
Even though we build, as you all know,
we still face failures.
While we are designing these platforms,
how can we ensure
these platforms can be
recovered from those
failure points?
Unexpected chaos.
So the fall tolerance,
when we design building a bridge
with a structure redundant pillars,
we always ensure if something goes wrong
with one of those structure,
the bridge is still up.
Similarly, when we are
building a platform,
we need to ensure
if a component has failed,
is our platform still serviceable?
And we also measure our
meantime to recover.
So when a failure happens,
how quickly we are going
to identify the failure?
How can we isolate from that failure?
How quickly we can auto
resolve from that failure?
These are very critical.
Reliability.
Reliability, I treat it
as a engine for trust.
So along with availability
and as well as resiliency,
it is also very important
the capabilities that are
provided by our platform
are functioning as intended
over a period of time.
That is going to ensure the
trust with our platform,
with our users.
Our users, our customers are
going to provide their data,
spend their time,
rely on our systems.
So with a lot of trust on these services,
as a platform builders, owners,
we need to ensure
how we can make sure
our capabilities are working as expected
and also reliable,
scalable, and trustworthy.
To get more details on the how part,
I'm going to hand it over to Arun
who can get into the
details of our architectural
practices and best practices
that we adopted throughout this journey.
- Thank you, Sobhan.
Cool, nice.
(audience clapping)
All the good things have to
have start like this, okay?
Cool. So I have about 47 minutes,
a lot of engineering content relating to
reliability, engineering,
and resilience engineering
on Capital One approach
to accomplish those.
So I'm going to dive deep.
So there are two focus areas in my talk.
So in my first focus area,
I'm going to dive deep
into the architectural
strategies that we follow
and architectural pitfalls
we had in the past
and our architectural journey.
Basically, our architectural evolution
towards the high
availability, high resiliency.
And then, I will talk about
our serverless adoption,
like why we are doing
serverless in Capital One
and how it is improving
the reliability aspects of
our system that we built.
A lot of times, I tend to see,
when we talk about
resiliency and reliability,
we just stuck with the
architecture, right?
So there are a lot of
non-architectural aspects
that impacts your
reliability of the system.
So I'm going to dive deep into
the different failure modes
that could impact your platform services.
And then, I will talk about
the Zero DownTime Deployments
using AWS CodeDeploy,
CodeDeploy, excuse me.
And then I will also use about,
I will talk about the reliable
infrastructure building
using the AWS CDKs,
and then I will jump onto
resiliency testing framework that we built
using the AWS FIS,
and then I will finally wrap it up
with the observability standards.
Resilient architecture, right?
So architecture is the
foundational building blocks
to build any system.
So when I talk about architecture,
I'm talking about the system architecture
and as well as the
deployment architecture.
So these are all the building blocks
and resiliency and reliability
shouldn't be an afterthought.
The moment we go build
something into the architecture,
if we add more components
into the architecture,
we need to bring the shift-left,
thought processing about the reliability
into the architecture.
So let me start with
some of the anti-patterns
that we had in the past
in the pre-platform world
because Sobhan talked about
some of the non-standard architectures
and the pitfalls that we had.
Let's start with this.
We call this as a "all-in-one approach".
You can see a lot of
single point of failures
in this approach, right?
So we have all these platform capabilities
packaged into a single monolith.
It deploys into a single AWS region
with a single availability zone
with no autoscaling
and no database replication, right?
This pattern is a big no in Capital One.
From the day one of Capital
One cloud migration journey,
we made a clear decision
that we are not going to
deploy in a single region
or with many single point of failures.
So we had always deployed our
services into two regions.
Then you might be wondering
why I'm talking about this now, right?
We had a recent US East one
outage in AWS in October.
All of our systems were able
to quickly recover from it
by auto failover to the other region.
But I have seen like some of the systems
outside of Capital One
had struggled during this outage, right?
Because they were heavily
reliant on a single region
with no other region to run their systems.
This is a big no.
If in 2026,
if you're still thinking about
having a multiple regions,
you are in this room because
you think that resiliency is important.
You cannot take your car
to a road without an insurance, right?
The same concept.
You have to have multiple regions
for higher resiliency
and higher reliability.
So our wide single point of failures
is one architectural bad pattern.
The next one that we have seen in our
pre-platform paradigm
is having these
multiple proliferation of microservices
with zero fault tolerance.
So the moment we talked about
monolith move to a
microservices based approach,
we tend to create a lot of microservices
with a tightly coupled nature.
So if one service goes down,
it impacts the all the other services.
So when we think about that microservices,
think about in a way that
every single service should be able to
service capability
and avoid cascading failures.
So this example,
if one service goes down here,
the customer is impacted
because all these services
are tightly coupled
in order to provide a
capability to the customer.
So this is an architectural anti-pattern
for high resiliency,
for a low resiliency.
And then, we talk about another deployment
pattern we had was,
in the pre-platform paradigm,
this is the deployment anti-pattern
where we had a single cluster
that was sharing the
same traffic patterns.
So we had web and mobile customers
using the realtime clusters
and also at the same time,
the batch load was hitting
our real time clusters.
So this caused pressure into our systems,
a lot of database timeouts,
and it impacted the real
time users experience.
So with this you cannot
reach a high availability.
So this is an anti-pattern.
All the system that we are building
in the modern platform world,
we have routed all the batch traffic
into a separate cluster
by using step functions
or other vendor products
for a batch execution model.
The other one that we had
in the pre-platform paradigm
was having the single database
that is used to share
between the analytical loads
on the real time customer loads.
So whenever the analytical job runs,
it goes and hacks the system resources.
When it hacks the system resources,
we started to getting a lot of
database timeouts on throttle
and it impacted our user experience.
So this is another anti-pattern
that existed in our pre-platform world.
Cool.
So I talked about most
of the anti-patterns
that impacted our high reliability.
Let's talk about some of
the patterns that we follow
and what are the
enterprise architectural
standards we follow.
When it comes to deployment,
we all the time deploy into two regions.
All of our CICD pipeline
will deploy the same version of software
into the two different regions
and all of our services are scaled out
so that they are anytime
capable of taking the load in one region.
And when it comes to the
architectural dependency,
no single region should
have a tight coupling
or any dependency with the cross region.
So all these services should
have the regional affinity.
Think of this when you failover
to one region to the other region
because your region one is impaired,
but if you still have a dependency
with the impaired region,
you are not solving the problem.
So you're still defeating the
purpose of having two regions.
So our guidance for you
is all these region services
should have the regional affinity
and should operate in a silo.
If you have any other dependencies,
in our systems,
we have other platform dependencies
within Capital One systems.
So we maintain the same
level of resiliency standards
across all of our systems.
So if I have a top-tier
resiliency standards,
all my dependencies
should also follow the
same resiliency standards.
And when it comes to data consistency,
we always tend to choose
the databases that are auto replicable.
When it comes to failure
recovery management,
any single region failure
should not cause impact to
our service capabilities
and all of our services should be equipped
with auto failover
and all of our platform services
have a very strict RTO and RPO defined.
So the bottom line here is,
when we are aiming for building
a high reliable system,
we need to clearly define
what are the goals we
are trying to achieve?
Without goals,
you cannot track your resiliency
or reliability aspirations.
So let's move on to the
architectural patterns.
Putting the words into a diagram,
you can see
we follow the domain-driven
design pattern.
All of our modern platforms
follow domain-driven design pattern
because domain-driven design gives us
high flexibility.
This creates the modular services
which are highly decoupled
and fault tolerant.
To think of this in this way,
think of this bigger domain
and divide this bigger domain
into multiple sub domains.
These sub domains have their own entities,
aggregates,
and their own database and layers
and they heavily operate
on a bounded context.
Now, think this into a platform model.
You have a platform,
this platform has multiple capabilities.
Each capability has its one entities,
aggregate models, and value objects
and they do not depend on each other.
So every capability runs
in a single bounded context
with no dependency with
the other capability.
With the banking example,
this banking domain as a larger domain,
you can divide this multiple
banking domain into sub domains
like a transaction processing service,
a reporting service,
a customer management and account service.
The bottom line here is these
sub-domains are operated independently
and every capability has its own SLAs.
You are not targeting all these services
to be five nine available or
three nine available, right?
So you can set different uptime
SLAs and response time SLAs
and domain-driven design is best for this.
What are the other benefits that we have?
These domain-driven designs are modular,
which means those services
are easy to maintain,
repair, and replace
and they operate in a bounded context
in a highly decoupled
manner, fault tolerant
and they're independently scalable.
And these service capabilities
gives you the SLA flexibility.
And not only that,
our customers
now pick and choose the capability
they want to connect to.
For example,
our finance will use a reporting module
whereas our card and bank will use
capabilities like transaction processing.
So this offers the extreme flexibility.
So now putting these words into a diagram.
So this is the minimum requirement
to deploy in Capital One.
Two regions,
multiple availability zone,
domain driven design with
bounded contact services,
autoscaling enabled,
and you have a database that's
auto replicate the data.
And then we have this R53 record sets
that has two types, right?
One, we have a geo based location.
So every request that
comes from the customer
goes to the nearest data
center of the customer.
And after that we also have
the failover record set.
This failover record set
is the mechanism for us
to do the auto failover.
This failover record set has two routes.
The primary route goes to the nearest
region of the customer.
The secondary route always
take care of the failover mechanisms.
It keeps an eye on the
other region's health.
And the moment we find out
that your primary region
is faulty, impaired,
this auto failover will
kick in using the R53
auto failover record set.
All of that is done automatically.
So this is the minimum deployment
architecture requirement for us,
but this is giving us
guaranteed three nine
availability up to four nine availability.
But there are some mission
critical applications
that requires five nine availability
and let's look into what
are the challenges we have
in this architecture pattern.
So now, imagine you have 10 customers
and you have two regions
and you have these
bounded contact services
and all the good things I talked about.
Let me introduce something
called poison pill request.
Poison pill requests are type of requests
that are capable of killing
your services every single time
they get processed, right?
It could cause a memory outage
or it could cause some
saturation into your resources
or it causes high database
timeouts or retry storms.
But the bottom line here is
every single time it causes an outage
very consistently.
Now, think this poison pill
and apply into our architecture.
Customer C2 is sending
a poison pill request
and we have the router
that sends the request to the region one,
the region will have multiple task.
So now this possible request
goes to the service task one,
the service task one will crash.
We have a ALB in front
of the service tasks.
So the ALB operates in
a round robin manner.
Every time when a
customer sends a request,
it goes to the service task one crashes,
service task two crashes,
service three crashes.
Now, guess what?
Now we have our auto failover will kick in
because our auto failover will think
the region one is impaired
because all the services
are getting crashed.
We have our alerts based on
the unhealthy host count.
on HTTP error codes.
So now, the R53 will think
that our region is down
so it'll automatically flip
the traffic to the region two.
But now, what will happen?
The customer is still sending
the poison pill request.
Now, the request will
go to the region two.
In the region two,
it'll start killing the
task one after the other.
So now, it is more bad than
the previous situation, right?
So you are not only
impacting the region one,
you are also now impacting the region two.
Now, how are we solving this problem?
We are creating a circuit breaker.
Typically, with the
circuit breaker is used
in the microservices world
when we have a dependency,
the dependency is struggling.
We do not want to overwhelm the dependency
so we'll wait for a minute.
We are shifting left
that circuit breaker
capability into our router.
Our circuit breaker has
a customer level metrics.
So our circuit breakers are enabled
with observability that
tracks poison pill request
from a customer level.
The moment we find out that customer is
sending a poison pill request,
we'll open the circuit
and we will stop taking the request.
We also have this router
enabled with the rate limiters
because sometimes our customer
used to overwhelm the systems
and cause reliability issues.
Even though the we have
these two capabilities,
these are more reactive
capabilities, right?
Because when we talk about five nines,
your budget for error
or downtime in a year is five minutes.
When these things happen,
you already breach that
reliability aspirations.
So your reliability goals is down.
This is reactive system.
What are we doing now?
Think of this.
So we have been designing
sharding techniques.
We went with this design one
using the standard sharding pattern
where we have these three shards,
three customer groups,
and we have a consistent hashing algorithm
that always creates a
stickiness session, right?
So customer group one always
get attached to the shard one,
group two goes to shard two,
group three goes to the shard three.
Now, imagine customer C6 is
sending the poison pill request,
it goes to the shard one
and then it completely
takes down the shard one
but your other customer
groups are not impacted
because now your request
is going to the shard one.
Is this good enough?
This is not good enough for us
because now imagine that we did
not have the circuit breaker
or we did not have this rate limiters
and things like that.
We used to have the blast
radius of a hundred percent.
Now, after this shard technique,
now our blast series is reduced to 33%.
Now, out of 10 customers,
you are only impacting three customers
because the other customers
are having the healthy shards.
Is this good enough for us to
build a five nine services?
Definitely not.
So where we are heading towards
is the shuffle sharding patterns.
I'm pretty sure
everyone in this room would've
played playing cards, right?
So you have the deck of playing cards
and then you shuffle the cards
and you'll have multiple players
and then you'll create the combinations
and then you will deal five, seven,
or three cards according to the game
and then you will try to
create the combinations.
The same concept is applied here.
So imagine you have this deck of cards
as the deck of shards.
So you have now multiple shards.
Now you have multiple customers.
So you create the multiple
combination of shards
and you will,
every time you onboard a customer,
you'll create a unique combination
and you will attach a
particular shard to a customer.
So in this diagram
you can take a close look
into the customer one
and customer three.
They're having, in the middle block,
they're having this same shard, shard 30.
Now, think of this poison pill situation.
Customer one is sending
a poison pill request,
it'll only impact
the shard that he belongs to shard one,
shard 30, and shard 70.
Even though customer three
shard 30 is impacted,
the customer three has
other two healthy shards.
So either the customer retries
or internally when we retry,
the customer's three's request
will go to the shard seven
or shard 99.
At the same time,
if the shard 30 had a problem,
if there is a database
problem or a shard problem,
the customer one or customer three,
either of them or not impacted
because they have the other
healthy shards to use.
This is the pattern
that has been proven to
be very useful for us
to achieve the five nines.
How do we create this
multiple shard combinations?
So that is this mathematical formula,
binomial coefficient.
You key in these different values.
In my examples, I have
these hundred shards,
a million customer
and I'm trying to assign
three shards per customer.
So with this mathematical formula
I'm getting 161,700 unique combinations.
These unique combinations of shards
will be split across
the different customers,
in this case a million customer.
So the success of this model will be
depends on how do you
reduce the overlapping.
So with this formula,
at any given point of time,
seven customers will have the
same combination of shards.
So now, think of this
from the a hundred percent blast radius
to the 33% of blast radius.
We have come down to 0.0007
percentage of blast radius
because of this shuffle
sharding technique.
So this has been proven
to be very helpful for us
to reach the five nine
for some of the mission
critical applications.
Where do we put this logic?
So this is a sample python code
to create the different
shard combinations.
So you key in your number of customers,
the number of nodes you want
and the shard per customers you want.
Then this code will output
the number of different shard combinations
that you want to create.
In this example,
you can see customer C1
is having S2, S4, and S5,
and customer 100 is having S2, S4, and S5.
Where does this logic sits?
So we have this router.
This router is where this logic sits.
So every single time when
a customer is onboarded,
this router will create the shuffle,
the router will create the
combinations of the shuffle,
and it'll attach it to the customer
with the durable storage.
So we have the database
attached to the router.
So the router will create this combination
and will create the stickiness
with the customer and
the number of shards.
And also before the shards,
we also have the load balancer.
The load balancer by nature, by default,
is a round robin algorithm.
So every single time a
customer sends a request,
in this example,
you can take a close
look into customer C1.
Imagine C1 is sending a request, at first,
with he has a shard S1, S2, and S6.
The first time the router will know,
oh, this is the first request
the customer is sending
and the shard he belongs
to is S1, S2, and S6
and I have the round robin algorithm
built within me.
So it'll set the header as S1.
So now, this header will
send it to the load balancer.
This load balancer based
on the header based routing
will send it to the shard.
And the second time when the
customer sent the request,
the router will attach the header as S2
and the request will go to the S2,
on the third time, S6.
It goes to the S6 and so on and so forth.
When you think of shard,
you can think the shard as target groups
in ECS tasks, right?
Every shard that I shown
is a ECS target group.
So they can be independently
scaled within that shard.
There was another way of achieving this.
We explored this way of achieving this
by shift-left the skip
the sharding mechanism into an SDK.
So our platforms have an SDK
where this code that I shown
lies on this SDK.
This SDK now knows the
back backend capability.
Like what's the capacity of the backend?
How many shots are running,
and how many customers
are going to be onboarded,
and how many shards per
customer I need to assign?
So this SDK will create this combinations
and create the headers
and every single time
it'll send the request
to the load balancer.
With this approach,
you avoid the router.
But the biggest problem with this approach
is that every single time
you make a code change
or if you want to make a
version change on the SDK,
you have to chase all your customers
and have have them enforce them to
take the latest version of the SDK.
So for this reason,
maintaining this SDK will
be a challenging aspect.
So we are pretty much going to incline
with the router approach.
We talked a lot about architecture.
What are the recommendations, right?
So multiple regions,
multiple availability zones,
and use the domain-driven
design if applicable to you
and use autoscaling our retrace drones
and try to use fail fast timeouts
because we had some reliability issues
due to the high timeouts
and use some of these sharding techniques
that fits best for your use cases
because managing the infrastructure
for the sharding will
be a challenging for you
and be aware of different failure modes.
I'm gonna talk about
different failure modes
in the later part of the session.
And when we talk about five nines,
we are not talking about
all your platform capability
must be five nines, right?
Because the only the
mission critical capability
should be five nines.
It is very hard to manage
a five nine service.
Cool.
We are also a serverless company.
Why are we moving to the serverless?
Because we had some critical loads
that were running on EC2 instances
and that caused some reliability issues.
I will give you some couple of examples.
So we had this docket containers
running on the EC2 instances
and whenever we want to scale out,
we had few incidents like where the
specific instance type was not available,
the IPSR ran out,
so we couldn't autoscale
in a timely manner.
And also, whenever we autoscale,
EC2 takes a lot of lead
time to come up, right?
You need to bring out EC2,
run the user scripts
and then we bring the docker up.
It takes a lot of time for
the EC2 based instances
to come and take the request.
Not only that,
it also created some operational problems.
So managing a fleet of thousands
of notes of EC2 instances
and every single time we have
to patch them, manage them,
it was a big human toil for us, right?
And it also created
some reliability issues.
When we tried to update EC2s,
we we did some manual errors
and they did cause some outages.
That's the reason that
we moved to serverless.
So with serverless,
none of this manual
operations or anymore exist
and we are able to like reliably scale out
and all our operational overhead
has been taken care, right?
Because if you are in Cloud,
if you're still managing
the EC2 instances,
you have to consider that, right?
You have to reconsider that,
try to adapt to a serverless technology
and especially all of our critical,
mission critical
platforms are running with
ECS Fargate services.
When you talk about AWS Lambda,
I want to make a note of here
a note out of it here, right?
So AWS Lambdas is that
we use on a non-critical
asynchronous path
because in the past we had
some reliability issues.
Make sure that whenever you
run the AWS Lambda functions,
you create bulkhead patterns
between these functions
by setting the maximum concurrency
limit to the AWS Lambdas
because they have the
tendency to go and occupy
the entire account
level concurrency limits
if you're not careful about that.
So that will cause some
reliability incidents to you.
And these are all the
different serverless functions,
serverless services that
we use in Capital One
and we are greatly getting benefited.
This has been a biggest
game changer for us.
It's been operationally
we are really efficient
with this adoption.
Let's talk about failure modes.
Failure modes.
We constantly review our
different failure modes, right?
So these are all the
failure modes we look into.
Your Cloud profiler will fail you.
Your internal platforms
dependency could fail you
or external vendors could fail you.
Our customers can send
a poison pill request
and fail your systems
or your own platform
engineers will cost some bucks
and create a reliability problems.
And the last one is the UnTrusted Code.
This is a very special condition
where we are building a platform
where we take this business logic
from our internal developers
from a different business units.
Like for instance,
we have a card business unit
and bank business unit.
They will pack their
business logic in the code
and then ship it to us
and we will execute it in our platform.
So this is not causing a security issue,
this is causing a reliability issue.
I'm gonna talk about
that a little bit here.
We had this design
in our version one
where our services and this untrusted code
were sharing the same VM resources, right?
So what happens when you get a request,
we'll call this untrusted code function.
And in a separate thread,
even though they run a,
we run a separate thread,
they share the underlying JVMs
and underlying VMs and things like that.
Now, imagine this untrusted code
had something like a system dot exit
or it has some wild through loop.
The code is constantly running nonstop
or it has a recursion it causing some
stack workflow errors, right?
There are possibilities
either intentionally or unintentionally,
our internal developers could bring
reliability issues into
these platforms like this.
So for this kind of platforms,
we are moving towards the
"Sandbox Safety Model".
So in the Sandbox Safety Model,
we'll create multiple micro JVMs.
So these multiple micro JVMs are
heavily built with bounded context.
So these service VMs are never
shared with this micro VMs.
Our untrusted code
will be allocated a very fixed capacity
of let's say 10 mb
and we set a very strict
timeline of execution
like the timeouts
for every single function execution
and we'll strictly prohibit
the IO access spots.
So this untrusted code
can never access the
critical file system path
and cause an outage.
So if in case,
if you're running a malicious code
inside this untrusted block of sandbox,
whatever happens between this sandbox
will just stay within the sandbox.
It'll never impact your service
because you're not sharing
anything with the untrusted code.
If you are building a
platform similar to this,
I highly recommend you
to go and read about the
sandbox safety approach.
Cool. So that's a lot of non...
A lot of architectural context
and let's move on to some of
the non-architectural context.
What are the challenges we had?
So we talked about a lot of
infrastructure management
and things like that.
One of the biggest challenge we had was
infrastructure management.
Why?
Because our infrastructure
as a generation one pipeline,
our generation one pipeline
was heavily AML based.
So there are multiple values,
multiple environments,
multiple copy paste
and it was used to be
a lot of manual errors
and it caused some reliability problems.
To give you a couple of examples,
we had some port misconfiguration.
Instead of port 8080,
someone did port 808,
they missed the last digit, right?
That caused a reliability instant.
And our pipeline did not have
drift detection capability.
So we had one setup is
running in the Cloud
but your repository is
completely different.
So the next time when
you go and create it,
the infrastructure,
you'll be creating the infrastructure
with the faulty configuration
and that has caused a
reliability incident.
What we are doing.
We are taking quantum leap.
We are trying to mitigate this with
complete automation using AWS CDK
because
when we talk about reliability
architecture is one thing
and these non-architectural things
that infrastructures and code releases
have to support your reliability goals.
So I talked about CDK,
so now we are taking this quantum leap
from infrastructure as configuration
into infrastructure as code.
We manage our complete
infrastructure using code.
We use the AWS CDK for that.
AWS CDK is the Cloud
development kit.
Now, think of this,
you have some R53s,
ALBs,
and ECS containers and things like that.
If I say all of this can be coded,
instead of using a vendor specific,
domain specific language
or a AML file,
all of this can be coded
in an imperative programming language way
such as TypeScript, Java, Go, or Python,
things like that, right?
So it unblocks the capability.
This is an example of an AWS CDK code
where I'm trying to create
ECS fargate service behind an ALB.
And whenever you create this,
this underneath creates a
Cloud formation template
and the infrastructure is managed
using the Cloud formation templates
and it unblocks the capability
of writing test cases.
So the moment you write code,
you now can write code to
test your infrastructure.
So in this example, you can see
I'm trying to verify
whether I'm using the ALB
with the right SL certificate.
If not,
I'm not going to create this.
This test case will fail
in my developer mission
and as well as in the CICD pipeline.
So this is the shift-lift
testing capability.
It's the biggest game changer for us.
We are no longer creating
faulty infrastructures
or causing incidents.
Another example of how
do you find this bugs.
So let's imagine that you
are trying to create ECS
task with 256 CPU
and some memory that is
non-standard for you.
So this can be cut much earlier
because in the V1 of our CICD pipeline,
we used to create the
resources in the Cloud
and then later we figured out,
okay, we create it with
the faulty configuration
and then we'll go back,
destroy the resources,
and then we'll rerun, fix it, correct it.
So we'll do this back and forth of fixing
and making sure the infrastructure
we created was correct
and it also caused some reliability issues
and also it was too much impact
to our developer
productivity and Cloud cost.
We also run infrastructure rules as code
using the CDK Nag.
So we have multiple rules that we run
like naming standards,
the ALB style port configurations,
or do you have the right
SSL ports open, right?
Things like that are also
managed using CDK Nag.
So infrastructure as code
offers this capability for you
and all these rules we run
in the developer machine
and in your pipeline
before we get created in the Cloud.
Let's talk about some of the
release techniques that we have.
So whenever we do releases,
we never take down the services, right?
We should not.
So we do the releases
while the customers
are using the services.
Let me bring back this
shuffle charting diagram here.
Just now, imagine that
we have a new version,
version in the blue box,
version N plus one.
Now, this blue box is
ready to go to production.
Now, instead of applying to
all these different charts,
I will pick and choose which shard
and which particular task I
should go and update, right?
Now in this example, customer group one
I will release to this customer group one,
I will just drop the code
into a particular task
and then replace
and I will constantly monitor the
behavior of the new version.
And if I get confident
then I will automatically roll the
new version to the other shards
under the other shards
and other shards and on.
How are we doing this?
It's completely using the CodeDeploy.
So we do not have any
manual release process.
So ever since we moved to
the AWS Fargate services,
the serverless services,
we are using CodeDeploys.
So CodeDeploy with the app spec deployment
configuration files,
we will just just orchestrate our releases
so we can say what is our
roll forward strategy?
What is our rollback strategy?
And things like that.
And CodeDeploy takes care
of everything for you.
The biggest force multiplier
of CodeDeploy is the
deployment lifecycle hooks.
So I've given highlighted
three examples here.
Before install,
after install,
and before allow traffic.
Before you install a particular
version of the software,
make sure that this software
has all the right configurations.
And after you install,
before you service the customer traffic,
make sure the release is actually correct
by running some synthetic
functional test, right?
Using the synthetic data.
So we run some functional
test in production
using some synthetic data
and ensure that the release is good
and we are not going to
break any reliability,
and before we allow the customer traffic,
because some of our systems
had some cold start problem.
So we use this capability,
this lifecycle hook,
to warm up our containers.
So this is Lambda example
that listens to all these
different lifecycle events.
So for every lifecycle event
we will run a different
pre-validation steps.
Another great part
is that all of this is
maintained in AWS CDK
include not only creating
our infrastructures,
also doing the releases
is maintained in AWS CDK as code
so that we test out
everything before we create.
Like I said,
we use the CodeDeploy
to do the gradual rollout
and we have this warranty period
before we completely
route the customer traffic
to the new version,
we will use the CodeDeploys
linear gradual growth
for traffic routing.
This is in another check that we do
called readiness checks.
We had some reliability incidents where,
to give you an example,
we had introduced a new capability
that required a Dynamodb table access
and we had an IAM bug.
So what happened?
We opened the customer traffic
and then the customer use case was failed
because the IAM policy was not updated.
So that incident taught us a lesson.
We should shift-left the capability
of checking the readiness
on the application side.
So our applications,
before they even come up,
they do this,
they call this custom IAM
simulate policy endpoint
and they will think,
okay I have to access these many services,
do I have the right access
before I take the customer traffic,
before I say I'm healthy
and attach it to the ALB,
this application itself
will do several checks
before it takes the customer traffic.
And this is, again, a game changer for us
with that lot of reliability
issues related to code releases
have been gone.
We also have these automated failover
and also we have the automated failback.
So the moment we failover,
we will create an event.
That event will be going to the AWS Lambda
and the AWS Lambda will
listen to this failover event
and it'll kick in,
and then it'll start
sending a particular load
to the unhealthy region
and it'll ensure that the
unhealthy region has come back up.
Sometimes we use the synthetic load
and sometimes we'll open
up a little bit of traffic,
customer traffic to check
the other region is good.
So all of this is automated.
So none of this, either the
failover or failback, is manual.
I want to spend a minute here.
Some of our critical
mission critical platforms
requires zero RTO/RPO goals
and they also require
cross-regional consistencies.
Think of this,
you're a new customer with a $0 balance.
You're now trying to make a $1 deposit
and we have Dynamodb global table.
So your request goes to the region one,
your $1 deposit goes to the region one.
We successfully processed it
and we persisted the data in
the Dynamodb global table.
But the data,
in order for the data to
replicate to the other region,
there is no guaranteed SLA.
It'll be eventually available
on the other region, right?
It could take few milliseconds,
few seconds, or even few
days or hours we do not know,
but it'll be eventually available.
Now, think that you made a
$1 deposit to the region one
and we failed over to region two.
Now we are trying to make
another $1 payment or a deposit.
It goes to the region two.
But now after the second transaction,
your balance will be still $1
because the other transaction
you made on the region one
have not replicated to the region two.
This has been a problem
for some of our mission
critical platforms,
which requires cross-region consistency.
So what we are exploring here is the
Dynamodb multi-region strong consistency
in which every single time
you write it to the Dynamodb,
it'll durably write it to the other region
in a strongly consistent manner
so that you failover,
you go read on the other region,
your data is available.
Some of our learnings using
the Cold Start, right?
So there are a couple of things
that impacted our high availability
because I am talking about this five nine
because when you talk about five nines,
your downtime budget is very low,
your added budget is very low.
So there were two scenarios
where we were impacted.
Once is the cold start
immediately after the release
and the other one is when
there is a long lull period.
So customer comes,
uses your platform
and there is a lull period,
they'll come back,
they use the platform again.
So every single time when
this pattern is repeated,
you'll see a spike in the response time.
Why this is a problem?
Because we have set a
clear response time SLA
of 500 millisecond
and every single time we breach that SLA
we will count that as not available.
Even though the request was successful,
it breached the response time SLA,
hence it counted as not available.
How are we mitigating this problem?
We are mitigating this
problem using the CodeDeploy
deployment hooks.
So the moment we deploy
the CodeDeploy deployment hook will know
the new version is deployed,
let me go and use this pre
warm script that I have.
So with that we are able to eliminate
the cold start problems.
Resilience testing as code
is another bigger area
that we have been doing.
You can also call that
as a chaos engineering.
If you remember,
I talked about the
different failure modes.
So what is the outcome of
the different failure modes?
So we will decide
for every failure mode we'll
apply a "what if" scenario.
What if your Cloud providers
region one has gone down?
couple of availabilities
have gone down?
What if your platform had a bug?
So we will convert the
different failure modes
into several "what if" scenarios.
After we convert the
several "what if" scenarios,
we will try to reverse those scenarios
in a very controlled environment.
When we reverse those environment,
it helps in two ways.
One, it helps to check whether
our alerts are working properly,
our runbooks are up to date,
and it helps tremendously
our engineers to prepare
and be prepared when the
real things happen, right?
So this is where we are
getting a biggest benefit
because it constantly
trains your engineers.
How are we doing this?
There's several different
"what if" scenario.
We are creating an AWS FAS based SDK
where we will use this gherkin format
and then we will define
in a simple gherkin format
the different failure scenarios
and then our SDK will convert into
the failure scenario testing.
We also do game days.
In our game days we will
completely isolate traffic
to the one of the regions
and we will see whether
our systems are able
to independently operate
in a single region.
So I talked about regional affinity.
So how do we test the regional
affinity by doing this?
So we'll completely isolate
and we will ensure the systems
running in the single region
is able to like take up the load
and that is no cross dependency.
Resilience testing
is the way you test your
architecture's resiliency, right?
We also do several
observability-related standardization.
We standardize all our logging.
So all our loggings are
based on structured logging.
This helps to immediately
identify the problems
and reduce the mean time
to identify the issues.
And we also standardize
the several metrics,
metrics related to,
saturation metrics related to
availability and error
budget and things like that.
And all of our platforms
are enabled with tracing.
So we have a distributed tracing
and we also have a continuous profiling.
Every single time,
we will run a continuous profiling
on a different versions
of the same function
and we use the histograms
to compare the performance
of the same function
with the different versions.
And we also do the error
code standardization
because error code
standardization is very important
because some errors needs a failover.
Some errors needs a N minus one.
Some error codes might need you to retry.
So you cannot have a single error code
for all your resiliency requirements.
So standardizing the error
code is another important thing
that we follow in Capital One
and which constantly message these KPIs.
What are our meantime between the failure,
meantime to identify an issue,
or meantime to recover from
an issue and things like that.
And another important thing that we do,
we have been doing in this space
is moving away from static
alerts into dynamic alerts.
We had this problem where if
you look into the left side,
we had the static alerts for
every five minutes window.
This alert,
right now measures
account of error that is
greater than a hundred for five minutes.
Now, imagine you have
for every five minutes,
you have 99 requests
on all the 99 are fail.
If that happens,
this alert will never go off, right?
Because even though you're
a hundred percent failure,
this alert is based on a static threshold,
which is a count of error.
In this scenario, it'll never go off.
So what we are doing is like
we are moving to a more
dynamic based alerts
based on the different traffic patterns.
Our low traffic analysis,
medium traffic patterns,
and then high throughput patterns.
For different patterns,
we have a different dynamic
thresholds and error budgets.
With this,
there is no way of we
are missing any alerts.
In the static alerts,
we used to miss a lot of alerts
because we are tracking a static number.
And then we have this kind of a dashboard
in all our platforms
where we have multiple shelves
of five minute intervals.
These green boxes are where our thresholds
were not breached.
And white boxes is where
there were no requests
come to our platform
and they're considered as good.
And our red boxes is where
like we breached the threshold
and we constantly review this
dashboard in a every day,
every week, every month.
And another important aspect
about running reliable systems
and resilient systems
is using these bulkhead patterns.
We had an incident where our service task
and our observability tool
were both sharing the
same resources, right?
And our observability
backend was having a problem
and that was creating a back
pressure to our service task
and it was impacting the
throughput of the service task.
So that incident cost us,
taught us a lesson that we need to create
and create a bounded context
between these services
and these axillary things like
loggings and audits and
retries and things like that.
So we are moving away from
tightly couple services
into a bulkhead patterns for
all of our axillary services.
We use these sidecar patterns.
Guess what?
Because of these serverless adoption,
using this sidecar pattern
has become very easy for us.
Imagine if you're running on EC2 instance.
If any of these axillary
systems are having a pressure,
it'll completely occupy
your EC2 instances resources
and it'll impact your services.
With the serverless adoption,
we are able to create these
sidecar patterns really well.
Why are we doing all these things?
Like talked about in the beginning,
we all wanted to create the trust
between the customers, right?
So customers trust,
they're highly reliable,
highly resilient, always on,
always secure,
always scalable systems.
Not only that,
there are other Four Cs,
Customers trust,
and competitive edge,
The moment your systems are not reliable,
your customers will start
using the other systems
and for highly regulated
industries as such,
we have to be always
adhered to our compliance
and also the company's reputations.
These are very important
and that's why we take the
resiliency very seriously
and every single time
we make a code commit
and we will push it to the production,
please make sure that you are responsible
for the company's reputation
and the customer's trust.
That's pretty much what I got.
Thanks for tuning in
and I hope that you got
something out of this
and you will bring it back
and build reliable systems
in your organizations.
Thanks a lot.
(audience applauding)